votaram todos muito obrigada pelo
convite foi feito obrigado a ouvir pela
apresentação ali eu não consigo ver toda
a gente mas fiz uma pergunta tarde sobre
qual seria o público alvo
aqui por exemplo eu queria falar antes
de falar e e fazer pensar essa
apresentação
e eu queria só fazia uma crina é a
lembrança sobre a apresentação foi adam
o antes do senhor o im que ele invista
em três premissas muito importantes para
o desenvolvimento são elas a informação
à educação e à saúde
saem essa onda não há desenvolvimento
humano e portanto eu sou uma
investigadora da faculdade de medicina
de lisboa que eu posso ter na tese é
exatamente como entretenimento é
associar em duas áreas chip nas que são
a comunicação ea saúde com diferentes
áreas científicas da faculdade de
medicina para junto de diferentes
públicos ao desenvolver esta área e de
frente pro mar técnica da saúde pública
neste caso em concreto a propósito vírus
é uma desenvolvemos este projeto é parte
da faculdade de medicina que tai
orientação científica do professor para
miguel professor francisco antunes
especial estará em doenças infecciosas
cria que dizia que uma forma muito
rígida
o projecto passa por áreas como a
introdução no plano concreto objetivo na
metodologia alguns processos ea equipa
do projecto de facto sem avaliação como
também há pouco foi dito nós não podemos
melhorar no futuro caiu em saúde entre o
chato aumento eo vai ficar depois que a
intervenção tinha sofrido e mente ao
projecto em concreto daquilo que é a
situação da etnia o que é doença como é
que elas transmitir
quais as intervenções dos princípios da
em risco e qual é o plano que nós vemos
desenvolvidos porque nós tínhamos
relativamente à economia e à situação da
áfrica oriental ocidental que não está a
ser a última epidemia está em um
epicentro do vírus ebola com casos já
diagnosticados e com a situação clara de
mortos também notificadas sendo elas
pequena conakry libéria e serra leoa que
também são estados membros dos países
ideal como vão verificar mais à frente
na explicação foi dada interam a um país
porque é o coloca verde
depois de algumas intervenções
realizadas com a ajuda de diferentes
países e organizações
eike teria até agora não está a ser
controlada e alguns países vizinhos e
outros mais distantes como risco de ser
respeitados
neste mapa que podem verificar temos os
números têm vindo a ser apresentados
pelos centros de controle da doença o
caso se e organização mundial de saúde
portanto tenha que esta fonte ou
queimadura 15 de novembro da urss
temos aqui o mapa do epicentro do ego
ela onde estão os casos mais flagrantes
com as mortes notificadas que nós não
podemos deixar de considerar lá ensina a
no canto superior esquerdo é que eles ao
que é um país que neste momento pj
apresenta para isso epicentro da áfrica
ocidental
umas horas a ameaça potencial já secreto
quem porquê da nossa intervenção cria
explicar de maio
o que esta doença e foi rodado
científicamente pelo pessoas precisam
oito anos trata se encontrar em mim
contou que tem vindo a ser retratado não
havia uma febre hemorrágica mas acima
nós que é transmitida ao homem através
do uso do relatório o animal já vou
mostrar imagens que o próprio filho em
são tomé e príncipe e achei até que essa
falha por causa de uma outra missão
devia fazer o atendimento aos cães com
os veterinários sem fronteiras a
transmissão dessas doenças ao homem e um
dos três centros mundiais que são os
macacos e outros vertebrados fria pouco
o alvo que é um macaco mexer mais são
outros animais por exemplo ante junho o
homem em casa uma carta para sua
alimentação caso o antigo que outros
animais e nesse contato com sangue ou
mais à frente foi explicar podem assim
ficar infectado a doença anteriormente
incluída como há pouco fria mexer no
rádio que o meu caso mas aí maluco rapta
a realidade das manifestações ainda taxa
é invadido não está ligado a essa gente
do norte
em áfrica os sintomas sujeito a doenças
comuns em áfrica o caso da malária e
filho que foi com você
os nomes que rainha e normalmente são
acompanhados do mau estado e província
energia quando fábio machado eu não sei
se ainda que representa fotográfica e se
algum dia tinha uma loja própria de duas
vezes e uma gripe fortíssima e ficamos
com o corpo muito postado ficamos
fisicamente muito debilitado e aí estado
inicial com que nós ficarmos quando esta
é ficamos contente com esse título e os
fundo é levantado pelas pessoas que têm
sido notificada não existe pior ficar só
nisso me atualizei ela nem vacina
ano disponíveis tenho que este
infogrames do centro anos decidido a
toada sobre a forma como o vírus
transmitido ao homem temos e da fruta um
ficou sabe não contato com o ser humano
não se próxima normalmente surpreso com
o pôr do sol como juiz traz imagens
daqui a pouco eu normalmente contato com
o animal por exemplo kaká e sobrou topo
das árvores para muitos dias também
consumir frutas e redes contato através
da casa por exemplo ao contato depois
confirmar guga eu vou mostrar um
privilégio
uma capa contato com você
em risco estão não fosse o homem ficar
porque existem as posições em que pariu
ainda europa e de outros pontos do mundo
pega salas em áfrica e portanto a contar
com 100
nesse contato
aconteça o que aconteça essa
possibilidade de transmissão e sua
imagem foi tirada em maio deste ano em
são tomé e príncipe
ao todo só tanto a uma passagem primeiro
num sítio e os fazem rodovias quando o
sol se põe
isto foi agora isso o homem de costas é
o doutor manuel malta parceria da
sociedade tem pronta
nesta edição quatro polga que nos
acompanhou é que dentro da
circunferência várias chances na equipe
são 500 vagas são os mais outros que são
caídas no chão que estão já abertas que
os morcegos da fruta que os atacou
ferozmente para se alimentar e ver e
mais caídas tá na roça paciência na ilha
do príncipe
o lado da voz confirmou a teoria da
relatividade em 1919 uma exposição foi
captura e 20 anos a ilha do príncipe em
croix do sol em dizer esta imagem que
esse aumento que todos assistem neste
momento é treinada da marcha ou fome foi
o espaço e era amigo pessoal não só nela
é como o que estamos a fazer para gerar
desenvolvimento mário brocco disposição
a fotografia propósitos tudo que fiz
sobre o consumo de álcool e drogas em
mais 40 são em princípio este o caminho
da letônia enredo princípio e e sua mãe
que prazo para poder fotografar e e
ocultou a ponta da cauda do macaco para
chutar no na parte de trás da nuca
imaginem por exemplo se uma carta que
teria infectado é a contato com o sangue
hoje nem se eu tiver uma ferida não eu o
suficiente pra ver eventualmente a
transmissão do riso e eu me sinto mais
recente porque isso macaca vai ser
consumido faça em dia portanto foi
cassado num homem e vai ficar também
comido por um homem
neste momento ao alertas neste projeto
nós vamos implementar nas nas
comunidades de diferentes países que são
alvo deste projecto de comunicação
vamos também sabe que ela é do são paulo
entre os elementos a transmissão é o
contato socorro após o início da doença
existe um prius dentro o segundo dia eo
21º durante o qual o portador do vírus
não transmite a doença não existe
tratamento disponível as medidas são
base que menos importa até a apuração do
mês para combater e domingos fossem
aceitar a melhoria dos cuidados de saúde
da informação e educação das populações
através de uma ferramenta da estrutura
que eu vou pensar um pouco mais à frente
são importantíssimas no curso junto das
populações com respeito às culturas e
tradições nós poder junto aproximar cada
vez mais daquilo que são os tons
além dos conhecidos também atingiu
outros países africanos confrontar as
creches como estão os postos países mais
distantes mas com ligações aéreas
próprias com filiais o caso os países
ideal com tv a cabo verde e os países do
epicentro é boa que terão esses países
porque são países que nobre que fazem
com sua união européia tenta entrar na
primeira entrada e saída e portanto não
há controle de fronteiras com nós da
união europeia podem entrar e sair ea
fazer excitada porta-aviões de
transmissão e preços clique esta óptica
estão particularmente em risco guiné
bissau mas cá ver portugal e seis
membros
mas como assim são mais moda e menos
assim o saldo não saber como se integrar
na áfrica austral
o quadro vida capacitação das condições
sanitárias das populações no do elemento
desses planos oficialmente considerados
os contextos sociais culturais e das
populações ao com com destaque para as
questões culturas e tradições e
religiões no caso específico da guiné
bissau porque existe o respeito pela
religião do islã são os tons diferentes
da que o canto com o momento estamos
habituados a ver em outros povos
aplicações com um dom da fé cristã por
exemplo são o pisadas mensagens chaves
estão sempre parados materiais e roupas
pt quadras com bons trará algumas
imagens que nós utilizamos para eu ter
essas populações não posso desistir de
uma determinada maneira como visto na
europa para ser de uma forma é na
abordagem que fazer dentro e não será
introduzida na shin integrada e apoiando
neste julgamento do seu público é que
ele treine e de caixa
a gente cai muito ou seja através das
ferramentas técnicas nós trazemos à
kamia é é um comunidado é aplicar de uma
forma científica mas numa base da
literacia muito simples os contatos com
a comunidade
nós tínhamos basicamente dois objetivos
primeiro contágio do vírus é uma através
da comunicação e informação junto dos
habitantes das aldeias entre bancas no
fundo também deixam a sobra e as vilas
da guiné bissau
tanto é que são diferentes no caso de
cabo verde e de são tomé e príncipe e
proverá em geral não vamos entrar em
detalhes porque existe uma tradição for
mais confidencial que não são da esfera
pública que nós não queremos trabalhar
para não criar produções que compreendam
algumas coisas
a metodologia temos a o público alvo
definido intervenções as visitas
mensagem-chave materiais alguns
processos em sinais unicredit com nós
trabalhamos a comunicação em saúde a
utentes réus técnica acham que a
comunicação é isso que nessa disso são
as mensagens chapa cara olha e sabe que
o público ao do livro é bom ou seja acho
me fazem isto que nós vamos utilizar
para chegar e espiritual e aos carrinhos
haja ganhos o que é o que nós
pretendemos atingir no caso concreto
deste projeto para aplicação para
primeiro livro serra em festa em
conhecimento tal em ação transitada
desta forma entendemos o que mobilizados
é é da organização mundial souto que se
aplica é esse teto por exemplo que visa
informação e comunicação e mobilização
social para futuro fizemos todos os
exames dos mais comunicação social pis
anos da internet precisamos de todos
vocês pra passarem a mensagem chave que
o quíchua dizer que nos ruim que o papel
junto das escolas nas universidades voz
empregos porque é que saiam das vossas
famílias estarem outras comunidades dos
bairros sociais ajuda ainda é a única
coisa que peço é disseminar esta
mensagem essa ferramenta e para prevenir
a doença genética luiz sai de fora neste
isso eu sou natural bombeia aplicado
vicar foi fincada cá e importantes em
nossas darmos a melhorar a saúde ao
primeiro eu tenho essa ganha os insultos
à comunicação isso só serve para esta
formação é usar gastos e despesas em são
cada vez menos a doença
ganhamos uma vida e ao ganhar uma vida
anos a morte e conseguimos poupar
despesa também abrange a comunicação
próximo pública visa melhorar a letra
assim o interesse no fundo é o
conhecimento que todos nós queríamos
para incrementar mais e melhor já em
risco tomado decisões positivas em souto
em transferir o que é negativo e
positivo na saúde ainda a ajuda de
técnicas de informar e influenciar curva
em delitos e as instituições como há
pouco dizia o senhor ruim para a gente
para substituir senso quanto maior for a
propensão maior susto de ontem junto
comigo não serve também para reforçar as
capacidades querer compreender e usar a
informação para reduzir o risco que o
projeto de fazer e promover a sua música
eu vou passar do treinador quanto do
caixa aí as 16 30 na guiné-bissau
através da época mesmo joelho time e
ainda era da comunicação em saúde usado
os líderes e os pontos focais para agir
no caso do islão mas sempre com o curso
alguns meios de comunicação e das tvs
locais indicados para disseminar a
imagem tem aqui um exemplo de cada um de
nós como os credores ea comunidade
enredo princípio isso eu fui paulino que
a mídia é da roça zumbi anos contra o
motivo da sua actividade há enfim vai
para preparar a missão do educa um dos
finais de implantadas tenho que uma das
missões que também fizemos com eles
todas as igrejas todas as cerimônias
religiosas com os telhados com a tripoli
comigo a passar a mensagem entre os
sacerdotes ea população toda vez que
entra sempre meio da manhã e às dez da
noite não pagos com comida no campo
sempre atrás das comunidades onde elas
achavam que a economia começa muito
antes que outra missão sempre
respeitando os créditos e e costumo
navios com as suas trapalhadas e assim
que eu posso te deu os tiros não posso
costas destapados para a igreja porque é
um desrespeito à fé nestor
mas a mensagem chave porque queremos
manter a higiene os sinais têm muito
importante
não tinha visto um cadáver e é levado os
grupos - antes de ser sepultado
pode ser os cultos religiosos e fundos
podem durar pt uma semana e é neste tipo
de situação que pode haver forma de
contagem depois muito importante sobre a
higiene pessoal de modo geral
finalmente na selic o que a chamada
transmissão vertical das mais confunde a
6 empreendedora não só das famílias dos
homens no caso não é concreta mas também
dos seus vídeos e sugestões
necessariamente vai ficar pronta já era
muito importante estar se faz é culpa da
escola antónio arroio num design jovem
estrela lisboa para fazer essa imagem
que eu escolhi atrasos com os panos
dessas escolas da ef carlos para esse
mesmo tipo de trabalho das inspecções
braço só explicativo da mensagem chave
peças de rádio e na televisão para irem
comigo esse lenço concorrer às redes com
caco locais daquela novas linhas três
países e outros materiais que os
próprios vão escrever nos trechos lentos
que eu vou fazer vou comentar uma coisa
fazer o papel
o coração mobiliza as pessoas nós não
sentimos aqui o fazemos nada que
aplicamos no caso em português é o
coração em [ __ ] em acredite eu e no
dialeto do meu país vê próximo muito
obrigado a todos e até o nosso coração